Matt friend is here who does the Howard
Stern impression how are you by the way
Robin you look beautiful right
thank you right is this still [__]
you up Howard it's [__] me up right
yeah right because when I start talking
to Robin after you leave I get crazy you
know right can we just talk about this
right guys right right or wrong right
right right
now it left or right right all right
right right right right right right
right right on red right right right
right right right Right Said Fred right
right Right Said Fred right right to
free speech right right right right
right right Robin Wright House of Cards
Right Robin Wright yeah right two wrongs
don't make a ride right right
let me fill in the blank you say
something I'll fill in the blank right a
woman's blank to choose right right
right
blank round baby blank right
let me show you that again right right
blank round baby blank right right round
baby right round right right hey
what gives you the blank to do this
impression on my show what gives you the
right the right the bill of black right
right right bill right Bill of Rights I
jerk off with my blank hand right right
hand right right as Matthew McConaughey
would say all right all right all right
right right right all right amen
wonderful before I go I just want to say
I'm gonna go take a pitch but first I do
want to tell you all about our good
friends
at Metamucil
ah Metamucil makes my duty flow that's
right Robin every [__] is a floater when
you use Metamucil crackers right hey all
right everybody
[Laughter]